[موسيقى]
اشهر منازل القمر الهلال واجملها البدر
والقمر قدرناه منازل حتى عاد كالعرجون
القديم والمع الاجرام السماويه كوكب
الزهره الذي يسميه العرب القدماء بالكوكب
الدري مثل نوره كمشكاه فيها مصباح المصباح
في زجاجه الزجاجه كانها كوكب دري وكوكب
الزهره يسمى عند العامه بنجمه العشاء ليش
لانه يظهر في وقت العشاء وفي مساء يوم
الجمعه سيقترن الاشهر بالاجمل سيقترن
الهلال بكوكب الزهره بشكل جميل ولافت
وبراق ناس عن ناس تفرق مو كل نجوم السماء
تبرق
[تصفيق]
وكوكب الزهره هو جمال الجهه الغربيه طوال
شهر رمضان وهو الكوكب الوحيد اللامع الذي
لا يرى قاطعنا الافق من الشرق الى الغرب
كحال الكواكب الثانيه ليش لانه واقع بيننا
وبين الشمس والعرب اسموه بالزهره لانه
يزهر بجماله وكانها لبهائها ولحسنها خلقت
من الياقوت والمرجان حارت حروف النور في
وصف التي اهوى واعجز حسنها
تبياني
[موسيقى]